morning everybody it is day two of this
Japan trip I don't know what we have
planned today but I think we're going to
go to Mount Fuji I just pray to God that
we're not walking up it because my
[ __ ] feet are killing me yeah
yesterday we were walking around I think
you were Shinjuku and Shibuya for like
about two twelve hours I think or so
like that then I gotta tell you
something
when you just don't don't be fat
hopefully it's gonna be dope I am tired
of [ __ ] still not use this time I woke
up here at 5:00 a.m. but I'm ready to go
ready to do this
hope you I like it and if you don't
what are we doing today
are you excited so excited you think
it's gonna be cold
yeah very fun I have a long sleeve and a
beanie and a fit this scarf and gloves I
can't wear a coat though it seemed
things me too uncomfortable
no I'm just gonna deal with it I think
it's gonna be cold maybe not for you to
hear that Joe ready for the adventure
yeah
today we do the advantage just no
bazookas Dukey though
do you think I'll get it
ah ladies onigiri time that sounded and
this looks like some egg from a crab a
Japanese real California hetero mmm
what's your eating what am i eating
Brandon costigan what's that um I don't
know some sort of onigiri that I'm
really failing at taking out but you
should take a bite cuz I think a little
bit was it good it's so good
we definitely know who wears genius
really I always wanted to fight someone
with the umbrella me too that's a very
odd dream have you ever had a dream that
this one was trying to jack your
something to get in I wanted to punch
through the window pulled him out one
man and then you stayed with him at the
vet piece of information I don't think
he's the crazy one because after he told
you that piece of information you're
like [ __ ] me still that's
thank you very much while we gotta do
stuff with hikes I thought a gondola was
in the water like in Italy
first of all calm mr. waters cool and
then it's not in the river and why did
you tell me that we're going through the
skies know what David I've seen you to
tell you oh that gondola takes us to the
crater but I was just told just now that
go to the crater due to weather
conditions that we might not feel
cynical all right but find other
activities student oh I'm so bummed out
you think we can't go on the gondola oh
I did too I was I'm scared of plant I
knew [ __ ] that's funny but Jessica do
you remember that time I choked you out
yeah but you're at that time I saw the
back you see so hard you pull out the
window I'm gonna convince the lady up
front that we're [ __ ] already by
yourself
mother what time you stood up in Japan
everybody thought you're Godzilla that's
funny cuz you're that first of all but
I'm cuter uh-huh look at you let me tell
you something else you're like a big
eyed [ __ ] those are just - I talk right
there right now right they are you lunge
to have you based on their calendar
nothing oh I can't wait
- you leave me a [ __ ] room right now
oh yeah okay are you guys planning to
have a kid talking about it yeah I'm
thinking about it
hold on we got a three month window to
lock everything Michael why had three
month window the bust nuts
what does it really matter what I mean
we're like a monkey from the Chinese oh
yeah all about the sales like you want a
monkey with the help in a minute process
of elimination
Bart can you just took a real quick
now kiss because either recording into
cupcaking for the past cute little
[ __ ] out Caesar right there I'll do
it
ah I like it when they float is [ __ ]
cutest [ __ ] dude cuz usually she says
stop touching me I think the other and
then when she does it's like magic mieze
yourself is you only get to get touch
when you want to be touched
I said you that's right on the peanuts
hell yeah we are still on the way to
Mount Fuji I have been fighting with geo
for the past hour
and I'm looking at the back of her head
just a serious really could you let me
walk for a [ __ ] second please yo you
ever seen your picture up in your vlogs
yes can you really share so because like
sometimes I just want to slice our
phones away the puzzle grandma my wig